is at risk of collapsing
the unstable roof seems ready to cave in
but she
her two children and five grandchildren
have nowhere else to go
for now they've been given monetary
assistance
we're very happy we've had help with
groceries i get 150 dollars a month to
shop
but the main reason she's happy is that
the albanian government
is giving her family an apartment in
these new developments in sumana
about 30 kilometers north of the capital
tirana
five buildings collapsed here when a
powerful earthquake struck albania in
2019
killing two dozen people in sumana alone
but anyone who lost their house will
receive a new one for free
and the government is paying their rent
in the meantime part of a dynamic
response to turn adversity to advantage
in the port of duras there are few signs
left that 25 people were killed by
collapsing hotels and houses
the sites of tragedy have been bulldozed
clean and listing buildings removed
we succeeded to transform the
response to the earthquake in a
success story people supported us
mostly because of how we reacted
exactly to covet an earthquake
so we turned these two blows
in two opportunities to
prove that we can we can do
we can do great things together and we
did the government has spent 150 million
dollars on earthquake reconstruction
this year alone
but the timing has been political more
than half that aid
was dispersed during the month before
april's general election
that helped prime minister eddie rama
win a third term
but it also means that for many people
their compensation arrived 18 months
after the earthquake
prolonging their misery ramazan dachi's
family say they haven't received
anything yet
municipal engineers didn't tell him his
damaged home is safe
guaranteed we sleep in fear that there
could be another earthquake and we'll
suffer more damage we have no assurance
that we're safe we're staying at our own
risk and we're very afraid
we've even disabled the front door lock
so we can run out into the street at a
moment's
local authorities gave dachi this tent
but he never used it
his neighbors told us they spent a year
in their tent and
ended up fixing their house at their own
expense
at the heart of this community 70 units
are going up first
to house the last of those still
homeless it's unclear whether people
will get to keep their damaged
properties
but eddie rama's earthquake response was
first and it helped him win an election
john saropolos al-jazeera thumana
albania